what did you you know a lot of people i
know you've heard this a million times
and you could like
uh denounce it or whatever but you know
they say that the second film
you know when you watch it there's a lot
of uh
you know undertones there are
sexual uh what what's the proper
terminology here well there's a subtext
let's let's call it like it is there's
the homosexual subtext of part two
the gay subtext is that freddy
is playing with the two boys he's in
their subconscious
mark patton and robert russeller
freddie's in their heads
they're having freddy nightmares so he's
playing with them he's toying
with their adolescent hormones and any
latent
homosexuality that might be present in
either of them
so that's there we played with that and
freddy plays with it there's a scene
where i
you know i i i i circle the boy's mouth
with my blade and practically french
kissing
right i remember talking to mark and
going mark was i'm gonna make this real
darkly erotic here we we were on top
jack was so busy
worrying about the effects and the money
and that constantly tick-tock clock
going you know when you're shooting
the jack doesn't remember you know that
we played with that but i know mark and
i talked about it i think
robert russell and i talked about bob
shay i think on the interviews he would
say like no i don't remember anything
like that i think he was the one
bob doesn't remember talking about it
because we were so worried about you
know getting
we shot in pasadena if you know anything
about shooting in pasadena
you got to have everything rolled up and
out of town by 10 30 at night although
you know it's a huge fine
right they had a lot of pressure on them
but bob shea
plays an s m bartender in the s m d
marx oh that's right the professor is
nice
it's definitely it's not you know
there's we right away
you know i right away i was getting all
his fan mail from kids that
loved you know sin and mark patton was
getting hurt
from from boys and girls that we're
saying oh we like seeing ourselves you
know we're troubled and
all of that and confusing and you know
and and
so we played it it was just it was just
one more element
yeah just sink your teeth into it it's
amazing what the movie's about
but it is a subtext in the movie it's
amazing that i as a kid when i watched
it it you know it scared the [ __ ] out of
me and i didn't recognize any of that
and then when i watched it as an adult i
go oh my gosh look at the door it says
keep out the boys if you watch any of
them there's some
there's sexual stuff at all oh yeah oh
yeah ready
you know there's a beauty in the beast
sexuality hidden there that's
always part of it but it's not you know
the the thing that
that people get wrong is imagining that
that freddie's a pedophile no no no
freddie
freddie's a child killer you want to
think of that poetically darkly poetic
like
like a like a adores song you know
jim morrison's classic cover of child
killer
you know alice cooper a child you know
or somebody
it's it's that darkly child killer has a
thing to it
he's killing the future children of the
future he's killing the future
dark and william blake and and creepy
and dark about that
you know so he's killing kids he does he
doesn't need to rape him
you know isn't that bad enough that he's
killing him yeah
yeah that's bad enough
you